>>Susannah Raub: Welcome. This talk is how
Maps API v3 came to be; tips, tricks, and
lessons learned in developing across-platform
desktop and mobile API.
My colleague, oh, before I start I would like
to remind you that we will have, you can follow
LiveNotes and ask questions about this session
on GoogleWave at this highly intuitive bitly
URL here: CNQIOK.
So, I'm Susannah Raub. I'm a developer on
the Google Maps API v3.
This is my colleague, Marc Ridey.
>>Marc: Hello.
>>Susannah Raub: And the real star of the
show is the Maps API v3 who graduated from
labs just yesterday.
So, big congratulations to, to our little
marker friend here.
[Applause]
>>Susannah Raub: And we're going to share
with you today things that we've learned in
developing this API so that it runs well on
both desktop and mobile devices.
This really was designed first for mobile.
The whole point of the project was to work
well on mobiles.
So, we're going to start by talking about
latency; the impact of it, the causes of it,
defining it, reducing it. Then, share with
you our architecture we've used, mostly to
combat latency.
I'll then hand it over to Marc to share with
you some of the technologies that we've studied
and used in developing this to work on each
platform.
And he'll also talk some about debugging on
Android mobile devices.
[pause]
So, in getting started, I'm going to share
with you some background on why we're here
today with the experience of the Maps API
one year ago.
So taking you back to April 2009, this is
your map.
[pause]
I'll stop it there. And so, after about 17
seconds, we finally have finished downloading
175 kilobytes of uncompressed JavaScript and
four, if we're very lucky, but normally six
images to render that map.
In those 17 seconds, if I was better prepared,
I could have gone, made a coffee, maybe come
back, but probably found else to do; not a
very good user experience.
This is really what we call "latency." Let
me back up and define it first.
There are a few kinds of latency. First, there's
"user-perceived latency."
This is the time until the page appears to
be usable.
In our case, this is when the map tiles, the
map imagery has loaded.
At this point, the user can look at the map
and start processing what's happening.
It seems to be usable.
Next is "page ready time." This is when it
really is usable.
And this, for us, is when the map is zoomable
and draggable; so, when the user can actually
interact with it.
And we separate these, because the user can
start to figure out what they're going to
do with the page.
It takes a moment to process what's going
to happen; what they're going to do before
they actually start doing it, before they
started dragging.
Preferably we want that draggable, that zooming
capability, to be there when they actually
start to use it.
Then, there's "page load time." And this is
the time until all elements are present.
We've really focused on reducing user-perceived
latency and the page ready time.
The page load time that we consider in there
is having all the controls loaded, being able
to load other things like directions and other
components of the map.
On the desktop, we can measure latency using
tools like HttpWatch in both Internet Explorer
and Firefox.
It gives us a breakdown of each request, how
much time it takes, where the time is spent
between waiting for the server, downloading,
whether the request has been processed by
the cache or not.
And it's really given us a good understanding
and we've been able to optimize a lot of things
over the years since the beginning of Maps
and v2 -- Maps API v2. By using tools like
HttpWatch to understand the sources of latency.
But, for any of you who've developed a mobile,
you're probably well aware that desktop and
mobile just aren't the same.
There's different causes of latency on the
mobile, and we need different tools to measure
it.
There's, we can take what we've learned from
the desktop and apply a lot of it to mobile
devices, but not all of it.
So, for understanding why it was taking 17
seconds to load the API, we had to set up
a new system to do that; not just using HttpWatch.
We noticed that loading the map took a really
long time, not just over the 3G network that
has high latency, but also over wireless.
So, we knew that it wasn't just the network
speed that was impacting the speed of our
map loading.
So to figure out what was going on, we used
the iPhone configuration tool and were able
to connect via a proxy server we had running
outside of our Corp network so that we could
access it on the 3G network.
We have a Fiddler proxy running on that server
that all requests go through and that we can
watch in Fiddler what's happening with each
request.
So this graph that I'm showing you, this chart
that I'm showing you here, is the breakdown
of the Maps API v3 loads.
So you can see between Lines 3 and 4, this
is the time that our big JavaScript file is
downloading.
It's not 175 kilobytes uncompressed anymore,
but it's still -- this is the time that it's
loading, it's parsing, it's executing --
before we begin to download our static imagery.
So what did we find?
We found that there is some overhead in downloading
-- or in parsing -- loading and parsing each
JavaScript file.
Plus some amount of time it takes to parse
and load it based on its size.
So, this chart is showing you that as the
file size increases, the amount of time to
load and parse is increasing, but the network
time isn't necessarily; it's reflected in
that, but we don't believe that's the major
source here.
We believe it's time taken on the phone; that
it's due to the limited CPU resources for
this JavaScript to parse.
It is very dependent, though, on the hardware
and the OS.
So, I have two charts here -- one on some
older -- on an older iPhone running a slightly
outdated OS.
And we see that the time decreases on newer
hardware on a newer OS.
The important thing here, though, is that
this is much improved from last year where
we were seeing a bigger overhead and a bigger
time but milliseconds per kilobyte load and
parse time.
So, things are improving.
But, with discovering that the size of the
JavaScript really matters, that we really
see this linear increase, potentially even
exponential increase in loading and parsing
larger files. We've needed to reduce the size.
And we were doing this, but for you writing
your applications, you're going to use the
compilers that exist to greatly reduce your
code size.
They optimize for code size reduction by doing
things like obfuscating property names.
So you can continue to use your beautiful,
readable, verbose, well-named, good style,
variable names, but not have that impact the
size of your final download by using a compiler
that's going to make them all short; make
them A and B and C.
The compilers also are a fantastic thing for
error checking and for helping you use good
practices in writing your JavaScript.
Some of these that exist are Closure, GWT,
the Google Web Toolkit, as well as a number
of other ones that you can find out more about
online.
The other thing that they do is, many of them
have built-in module, or fragment systems
that will split your JavaScript into multiple
components so that you can download only the
parts that you need instead of the big download
all at once.
That said, we want to reduce the number of
downloads.
So, we don't want to just put all of our components
into little tiny JavaScript files.
Remember, there's an overhead on a mobile
device for each download.
So -- and a common technique for images is
image spriting.
Instead of downloading these three marker
images, we can put them all in one image and
crop them in the browser using divs.
With JavaScript -- we want to -- after we've
split things into our modules, we want to
then combine them back together.
When we know that two components are going
to always be used together; they're better
off being served as one.
When we started bundling some of our modules,
we saw huge latency improvement on the mobile
devices.
So, instead of downloading three requests
for 15 to 25 kilobytes, we want to just download
one that's 57 kilobytes.
This is in the example of our API.
Now, caching is one of our favorite techniques
for reducing latency; not having to make a
round trip to the server, just accessing data
from the browser's cache.
But, mobiles are far more constrained than
desktops when it comes to caching.
Their file size restrictions, the total size
of the cache, is limited.
And maybe, most importantly, they're cleared
much more frequently.
For example, on the iPhone, when you close
every tab in Safari and close Safari, it clears
the cache.
For our API, we really depend on caching.
We expect that, because the API is quite popular,
that people may visit one site and download
the JavaScript and tiles.
And then, when they visit another site, those
files and images are already in their cache
or in some cache near them -- a server cache
near them.
With mobile, we can no longer depend on that.
We need to make things fast as if they're
always downloading our files for the first
time.
Fortunately, the cache, as well as the parsing
time for JavaScript, the cache is also improving
with each OS and hardware release.
A year ago, we were seeing things that the
iPhone could cache up to 20 items of no more
than 25 kilobytes uncompressed in its cache.
Now, we're caching many more files and many
larger files.
Things are looking up.
Next, though, you can -- as an alternative
to the cache -- if you can't count on that
data being there, there's the HTML5 database.
It's great for static files, because it allows
you to store data for your site on the phone
itself.
It's not great for dynamic content however,
and it's not easy to use cross-domain.
So, for our API, we've looked into it and
it doesn't make much sense for us because
we're always changing our versions and we're
running cross-domain -- everything we do is
cross-domain -- that -- not the solution for
us, but a great idea for regular applications
out there on the web.
So now, we'll share with you some of the architecture
choices we've made to reduce latency.
We recall that it took, to download that initial
map, 175 kilobytes of uncompressed JavaScript
and six images.
There's two things we need to improve there:
We would like to request fewer images and
we'd like to request them earlier.
The way that our API works, we need the full
interface to download -- that full library
to download -- with all of the classes and
methods the developer can call.
And then, once that has downloaded, the developer
can create a map, set the center and zoom
and map type, and at that point, we can start
downloading images.
That's a lot to happen.
And because that interface to get -- just
to create a G Map 2 and sender and set zoom
-- that needs to come with the full 175 kilobytes.
And we've made this promise to developers
of this large, synchronous, public interface.
There's a lot of classes and a lot of methods
in the API, and many of them, when you call
some method, you expect some other piece of
data available right then synchronously.
So changing that contract was really our real
limitation.
So, the full sequence here of what happens
-- we download what we call the "bootstrap."
This is what then specifies what version
-- either specified or the latest version
of the API is that we're going to download.
Then, we download that full interface library.
Then, we download the rest of the users or
the developer's page.
We then need to wait for the map to be initialized.
And, at that point, we can load images.
Then, we load everything else -- the drag
initialization or the controls -- other things
on the map.
So, we need to make that last blue part --
that load images -- much earlier, or shrink
the size of those steps before it.
And that was our goal in developing Maps API
v3.
What we chose to do is use a Model-View-Controller
architecture -- MVC.
In this pattern, the models store state synchronously
and that's all they do.
We then have views that are responsible for
rendering that state.
And that can all be done asynchronously --
meaning, they can all be downloaded later
in the pipeline.
We then have controllers that are go-betweens
between them.
I won't spend too much time talking about
them.
So, our initial download in v3 only contains
these models.
And then, the views and the controllers are
loaded on demand.
This means that, if you never create a marker,
we only have put a few hundred bytes in the
API that just give you the interface for the
marker but no actual marker functionality.
So, it looks like this.
Here's an example of the marker.
Oh, and -- so, the models that we put in that
first download are things like the Map, the
Marker, the InfoWindow.
Those are all examples of models.
If you've developed a V3, you're familiar
with these classes -- they are simple --
what we call "MVC objects" that set and get
properties and do nothing else.
So, with the marker, it has a position.
It's in lat/long space.
The view works in pixel space and all it does
is render things in the DOM.
But that's the bulk of the code with the marker
is calculating where it should be positioned
in the DOM and styling it correctly and all
the things that go along with creating image
elements.
We have a controller that sits between these
two things that converts between the lat/long
space and the pixel space, meaning that this
view is totally independent of anything having
to do with the map.
It really -- we could have this marker view
be totally unrelated to a map.
Or say, put it in a Street View object and
render it exactly the same, because all it
does is render images in a div.
So -- and this works on an event-based system
-- so, when we set the position on the marker
-- on the marker model, it then triggers
an event to the position controller.
The position controller has the right inputs
to convert that from a lat/long to a pixel
position.
It then sets its own pixel position which
triggers an event on the marker view.
And the marker view can then position itself
in the DOM.
This means that, as the developer, you called
set position. We then did all this behind-the-scene
stuff, which was all asynchronous -- you don't
really care.
You'll then get notified if we change the
position again with one of those same events.
But there's no need to have a lot of synchronous
functionality here.
So, in the end, the marker is very small,
having limited -- just setters and getters
-- limited functionality.
And you get events when things do change.
So, the next thing we need to optimize --
and this -- the MVC architecture allowed
us, with an interface almost as large as v2's
-- to reduce that 175 kilobytes uncompressed
to 32 kilobytes uncompressed.
Which compressed is about 11 or 12 kilobytes
that you download in order for us to get your
center, your zoom, your map type, so that
we can start rendering the map.
The other thing that we have living in our
main.js -- that we call it -- that first download,
the big one -- is, code to render a single
map tile.
We use our static map server, that when you
set the center and the zoom and the map type
-- because you can do that once you download
that first component -- that main.js -- once
you've set those we contact our static map
server, get a map to fit exactly your div,
and load that one first.
And then, fill in on top of it the regular
tiles that allow for the infinite zooming.
So, instead of downloading to get that map
to appear initially -- instead of downloading
six images of about 25 kilobytes each --
we download one image that's 40 kilobytes.
This cuts a few seconds off of our load time.
It brings what would be probably seven to
eight seconds down to four or five seconds
for that user-perceived latency on a mobile
device.
Now, it's great to study this in a controlled
environment and to study latency.
We also -- it's very important for us to measure
this in the real world.
We track how long our maps take so that we
can see the impact of certain changes on latency
and see what our users are actually experiencing;
see when things make it, see when changes
make it better and see when it makes it worse.
So, we see here, in a few months time, we
saw our small maps get faster and our big
maps maybe get slower.
This graph that I'm showing you -- the upper
line for very little traffic compared to the
lower line.
So, it's hard to know exactly what's going
on.
But this shows us we need to spend more time
with big maps on an iPhone perhaps.
Another way to reduce latency is to pre-fetch
-- that, when you know a user is going to
do something and they're going to do something
soon, to pre-fetch that data -- to load it
in the background -- so it's ready when you
want to use it.
This is great for latency.
Remember though, it can be bad for users
-- particularly users not in the U.S.
They may have limited or expensive data.
And they don't really like it when sites start
downloading a lot of stuff in the background.
It can also slow down other things that are
going on in the site.
So pre-fetch with caution.
Pre-fetch when it is highly likely that somebody
is going to want to use this content.
With that, I'm going to turn over the mic
to Marc Ridey, my colleague on the Maps API
v3 team, who's going to take you through some
of the technologies that we've been studying
and using.
>>Marc Ridey: Okay. So, technology -- I'm
going to talk to you about graphics, geolocation,
and touch and mouse events.
Graphics technology -- you have quite a range
of graphics technology available.
There is Scalable Vector Graphics, VML.
There is Canvas, Canvas 2D, Canvas 3D.
There is CSS Transform.
The problem with those technologies is really
that you haven't got all of them on every
browser.
You have a mix of support between browsers.
You have a mix of support between applying
systems.
Touch events and mouse events are supported
on some browsers and not on others.
So you have to adapt.
The main point is that you're going to have
to create different path for your sites --
different ways of rendering things -- and
take the most appropriate one, depending on
the type of browsers that you're facing.
So, we use a lot of graphics-intensive capabilities
in the polys, StreetView and in some of our
controls -- the compass control, for example.
So, I'm going to talk about some of those
things.
And I'm going to go through and trying to
give you a bit of an idea of where this different
technologies fits -- what the good things
and the bad things are about them -- and where
they are supported.
So, let's start with Scalar Vector Graphics.
So, Scalar Vector Graphics is great for rendering
polyline, polygons, 2D vector information.
It's quite fast. It has a lot of advantages.
It's retain mode, which means that if you
load data into an SVG control, it will remember
it.
And if you need to modify the thickness of
a line, you just find that line element, change
the thickness attribute, and the display will
be changed.
It's quite fast once the model is loaded.
Because it's DOM-based, it actually has very
good mouse event support.
So, if you click on a sub-element of an SVG
control, you'll get a click event that tells
you exactly which element has been clicked.
So, if you have a number of polygons on your
screen and you click on one, it will tell
you that that particular polygon has been
clicked, and it gives you the location of
the polygon.
So, all this is great -- good mouse support,
good DOM support, good fast support for polyline,
polygon.
The trade-off is that if you want to work
with images, well, it's not really designed
to work with images.
You can do transforms for images, but the
performance is really a bit bad.
It's also opaque to mouse events.
So, if you have a very large SVG control,
you can't really receive mouse events behind
it, even if it's transparent.
So that also creates some problems if you
place an SVG element in the middle of your
screen.
Support-wise -- it's supported by Firefox,
by Safari, by Chrome, but it's not supported
by Android and it's not supported by Internet
Explorer.
So, for Internet Explorer, where you have
DNA on that, they both appear about the same
time.
I don't remember which one came first.
And I don't know if it's Microsoft that started
to make a different SVG or SVG simplified
VML.
Not sure, I think there's some arguments there,
but they work the same way.
The syntax is a bit different, but they're
both DOM-based.
They're both retain mode.
They both have similar mouse supports.
So, in a sense, what we find in our code is
we have a lot of common code between SVG and
VML.
And when we dictate that it's IE, we render
the information in VML.
When we dictate that it's not IE, we render
it in SVG.
So very similar programming pattern there.
The nice thing about VML and SVG is that you
can either create that data through JavaScript;
create elements and then set attributes, or
you can directly create a lot of HTML, a string
that define your whole SVG or VML element,
and load that into your browser.
So you can pre-prepare the data service site
and fit it as part of your page.
So, when you have to do more image-intensive
work, you're left with Canvas.
So Canvas 2D -- it's fairly fast for manipulating
images.
You can transform images; you can crop images.
So, quite good.
It's not really designed to do polyline and
is polygons.
It can do it, but the problem with Canvas
is that it's not retain mode.
So, it means that, if I draw a hundred polygons,
I have to make thousands of calls to Canvas
to say, "Start here, draw there, draw there,
draw there, draw there, draw there," and so
on.
And "move there and draw again and move there
and draw again."
If I want to change one small attribute or
the position of one point, it's like a piece
of paper -- erase everything, and draw the
whole thing again.
So you don't really have the capability of
being able to modify a small part of your
Canvas.
The other part is, because it's a big piece
of paper, you have no mouse support.
In a sense that, if somebody clicks on the
Canvas, you'll get a message that says "The
Canvas has been clicked, and this is the xy-position."
If you've got a hundred polygons that have
been drawn, you're going to have to find,
in JavaScript, which polygon was clicked,
based on you're going to have to do your own
hit test.
There's no support in Canvas for click event
support.
Browser-wise, it's well supported.
Only Internet Explorer doesn't support it.
So, it's not bad.
Performance is -- really depends on browser
and on the plotting systems.
I'll show you later a table of the statistics
I extracted in my work on StreetView, and
you'll see that you can't take things for
granted, even when you look at a single browser
and think that the performance is going to
be the same across all the plotting system.
It's really not the case.
So, if you have to do something fast, do it
in Canvas 3D.
That would be great, but it's only supported
on 19 bit at the moment.
But it's fast. It is extremely fast. It's
retain mode.
You load all your geometry in WebGL and you
can access it.
You can modify it.
You don't really have to continuously, like
in Canvas 2D, redraw everything.
The mouse support is just as bad as Canvas
2D.
You will know that your Canvas has been clicked,
but you don't really know where it's been
clicked.
So, it has its good and its bad.
Now, CSS Transforms -- it doesn't completely
belong in this category, but you can apply
CSS transform on DOM element to do animation
and to do a bit of transform.
So, if you don't need to draw things, but
you just need to transform some of the element,
look into CSS transform. It's great for animations.
You can do CSS-based animation instead of
modifying the position of your elements.
And you can time them just by setting a style
with a timing and a start/end position.
You can create animations in CSS transform
that will be really fast.
Okay. So, what's happening there really is
that you end up with a code that has the IE
path, VML and HTML, and then, the rest of
the world.
Maybe it will change with IE9, but for the
moment you really end up with a GL-type approach
for your graphics.
So, this is the table of rendering.
So, when I render Street View, every time
you pen, I have to render a complete frame.
It's a lot of image cropping -- a lot of image
transformations.
It's thousands of calls into Canvas.
So, this is really pushing Canvas to the limit.
If you have to draw a few polygons and things
like that you'll never have this kind of problem.
But, if you start having to do thousands of
call to Canvas, this is the type of performance
you're going to be looking at.
So, as you can see, Chrome on Linux, Chrome
on Windows, Firefox on Linux, Safari on MacBook
and Windows, performance is not bad.
Okay, from 25 millisecond to 100 millisecond.
It's gives fairly good penning.
But then, Chrome on Mac, Firefox on Mac, Firefox
on Windows -- the performance there is just
unusable.
If you have start having five frames a second
or two frames a second, just -- you can't
really do any penning or any animation on
this kind of thing.
I've put here the iPad and iTouch figures
-- so, iPad at 800 milliseconds and iTouch
at 1900 milliseconds.
So you get a frame every two seconds.
Same thing, not usable.
And the new FroYo is at 314 milliseconds.
So, it's still what? Six times faster than
the iTouch, but not quite usable if you want
to do image-intensive work.
So, in this situation, what we've done with
Street View is that for Linux Chrome and Linux
Windows we actually use the Canvas 2D implementation
and, for everybody else, we use the HTML4
implementation which I will demonstrate shortly.
Now, WebGL -- that's where it gets exciting.
These are the timing for the same work done
in WebGL.
So rendering a frame in WebGL on Chrome Linux
-- 0.9 millisecond.
Rendering the same frame on Safari WebGL
-- 1.5 milliseconds.
Rendering it on Firefox -- on Window's XP
-- 1.1 millisecond. Okay?
So, at that level, just the performance --
the user interface -- is smooth.
It's all done in JavaScript talking to WebGL,
but it's really nice -- really have great
performance.
And I just can't wait to have WebGL just coming
out directly in mainstream.
Okay. So, what we ended up using?
For polygons and polylines, SVG and VML.
For most browsers, we fall back to Canvas
for Android because there's no SVG and VML
support.
For animation, we use CSS transforms.
We have no animation on IE.
For image transformation we use Canvas.
And we have no image transformation on IE
and on Android.
And for 3D transform, when it's there, we'll
be using WebGL.
I'm hoping it's coming soon.
I haven't heard about anything from IE9, so
I wouldn't hold my breath either.
Okay. So let me show you a couple of demos.
And what I'm trying to show you there is that
those technologies can be mixed.
So, where am I?
So, when we looked at this view here, what's
happening is, we have -- it's hard to see
on the white card there -- okay.
So, what I've got there is, I've got a links
control.
That links control is an SVG control.
I've got mouse support, I can do rollovers,
I can change the style -- that's my SVG control.
I've got another SVG control here which is
my compass control.
So I can rotate things when my view changes.
And then, on the background, I actually have
here on HTML4 layer for Street View, because
the performance on Chrome MacIntosh for Canvas
2D wasn't good enough.
So, if I switch to the Webkit Safari, which
is the night build, that is a similar view,
but here the performance -- that's WebGL,
okay?
This is this kind of thing.
You know, that's the kind of thing you're
going to be able to do with WebGL.
So, what I've got there is, I've got a background
with WebGL.
But, on top of that background, I still have
the SVG control for my links and the SVG control
for my compass.
So you mix the technology and use the one
that best fits what you need to do, okay?
So, if we switch to this little guy.
Sorry.
[pause]
Okay.
So, if we switch to this little guy, we have
the same thing.
And here, it's actually an HTML background
and the links control that we can hardly see
under the zoom button, but the links control
is actually a Canvas control.
And Canvas doesn't support text rendering
so, actually, we didn't put the text.
It's also a small display, so we didn't really
have the space to fit the text for those twits.
And because Canvas doesn't have mouse support,
what I've got on top of that Canvas control
is I've got transparent div that have been
CSS transformed.
So, they follow on top of the arrow.
So, when you click on the arrows, you're not
actually clicking the Canvas controls, you're
clicking some transparent div.
So, just think about all these things, and
think about how you can mix and match the
different technologies.
All right, let's go back to --
[pause]
No, it's gone.
Okay.
So, a few things to also remember.
Canvas 2D performance will increase every
time your Canvas size increase.
So you've got a number of problems.
One, as window Canvas bigger, you tend to
make more call.
In our case, make more call to Canvas.
You have more peak source to render for the
engine.
And those two things combined means that it
really gets slow.
It gets more than linearly worse.
So you don't want to use Canvas on a very
large desktop and just draw all over the place.
The performance is not going to be good.
There are a number of bugs with those technologies.
So, for example, I found there's a bug where
you combine treaty transforms with touch events.
So, things that you have to choose sometime
in different technologies.
Canvas, up until FroYo, had no support for
images on Canvas -- there was a bug there.
That's been fixed with FroYo this week.
So. it's good news.
WebGL only support it on night build.
And there is bugs when you enable CSS transform
events.
We've -- the support for embedded objects.
So, when you try to combine having a flash
object and putting CSS transform to position
it in a different location, you're not going
to get a very good result.
So, just be aware of all these things.
Okay. So let's talk about -- I'll be very
quick on geolocation.
The reason I want to be very quick on it is,
really, it's not difficult.
It's been covered in a number of sessions
today.
But the point to take home is that if you
want to do geolocation, use the W 3C implementation.
It's available in Firefox. It's available
on mobile devices.
And if you don't have geolocation available
built into the device, fall back to GoogleGears.
The two objects have the same interface.
So, if you have that little piece of code
in your application, you can just look at
if you have the geolocation available or if
you have GoogleGears available, and then,
just do your request, okay?
We don't provide it at the moment as part
of the API simply because it's just a few
lines of code you can put yourself.
We use it as part of a preview we have seen
a few days -- yesterday on the place of API.
So, mouse and touch event -- it's not a very
good news for mobiles at the moment.
So there is very good support for touch event
on the iPhone, iPad, iTouch.
There is fairly good support for touch event
on Android.
I mean, "fairly good" because there is no
support at the moment for Pinch-type event.
And then, after that, there is very much nothing.
We've tested the S16. We've tested Palm OS.
We've tested a number of devices.
And, up until now, those events are not available.
So, when you interact with the browser, you
can see that the browser will scale when you
pinch or will react.
But the fact is, at the JavaScript level,
you're not getting those events.
So, that's a bit of a problem.
The sequence of events you're getting is also
a bit different for each of the browsers.
So you're going to have to be careful in your
code.
Some browsers are going to swap the sequence
of events.
They're going to give you click events and
not give you mouse events or they're going
to give you mouse events and not click events.
So mobile technology at the moment -- there
isn't that much of a standard.
And you're going to have to test every device
as you go.
This is, at the moment, what the world looks
like for events.
So, there is very good support for iPhone,
iPad.
There is good support on Android.
And on the Samsungs, the Palm OS, the Nokias
we have tested, it's just click events.
The Nokia is doing something quite weird where
they simulate mouse over when you touch the
screen.
So if you touch your screen on the Nokia browser,
it will give you a mouse over event.
And when you move a mouse -- move then a mouse
out -- and when you let go, it will give you
a sequence of mouse up, mouse down, mouse
click.
So it makes for things a bit difficult.
Okay. Let's talk about debugging.
Susannah just brushed a bit about it.
So, debugging on desktop on the iPhone and
the Android.
Debugging on desktop, really, ten years of
development have done things fairly well.
We use Firebug on Firefox -- Visual Debugger
in the developer toolbar -- it's on Explorer.
We use Developer Consonance SpeedTracker.
If you haven't heard about SpeedTracker, find
the recording of the Chrome sessions that
were on yesterday and today and learn about
SpeedTracker.
It's really a great tool. And Safari with
the WebInspector.
Now, what do you do on the iPhone?
Susannah brushed on it. So, there isn't much.
You do some console tracking, and you enable
the debugger mode on Safari and get a few
lines of text.
It's a bit annoying, but that's all you're
going to be able to do.
If you want to do some performance testing,
research the use of the iPhone Configuration
Utility.
That will let you set proxy settings on your
3G settings.
If you launch your iPhone configuration utility,
find the advent settings.
Set up the proxy and set that configuration
on to your phone, and then, all your Http
traffic will go to a proxy server.
If you've got a window's machine, you install
Fiddler on it, enable it to become an external
proxy -- you will get the kind of charts that
this is giving you. Okay?
So you'll be able to find the start time,
the end time, the duration of all your transfers.
You'll be able to see the request header and
response header of all the requests you've
made.
So that allows you to monitor all your AJAX
queries, to look at what you were sending
and receiving.
So it's a great debugging tool for AJAX-style
application.
If you want to do the same thing on Android,
bit more difficult on some -- simple on others.
To do tracking, the best way is to plug in
your Android into a USB port and run the ADB
utility on your desktop.
So, go and download the Android SDK, install
the USB drivers that the SDK will prompt you
to install, and then, launch the ADB log CAD
application.
When you plug in your Android on your PC,
it will automatically stream all the information
that the Android is displaying directly on
the text console.
So you'll get information on the inside of
the Android a lot of track information.
But among all this, you'll see all the http
trace -- so great tool.
To do http proxy, simply go to the network
settings of your Android and find your network
access point names and under each access point
name you can go to the settings and add the
proxy value.
If you set a proxy and a port -- same thing
-- you can get all your 3G traffic to be
redirected to a proxy -- Fiddler proxy --
and get all the queries that you're making.
So quite nice.
This was broken in 2.1, but I think it's being
fixing for you.
Okay. That's the end of our presentation.
>>Susannah Raub: But we would like to remind
you that you can get qualified as a Google
developer.
So, to be recognized for your work as a developer
in your expertise.
And we will now be taking questions, both
from the floor and from Wave.
[discussing quietly]
>>Marc Ridey: So have you got any questions?
I can also answer some Street View questions
if you're interested.
[pause]
>>Q: Have you come up with any recommendations
aside from what we had last year for clustering
large amounts of markers?
>>Marc Ridey: Use KML.
>>Q: KML?
>>Marc Ridey: Yes, even for a small amount
of geometry, I think past 50 markers, you're
going to find that 50 markers or info Windows
or polyline, things like that, KML will give
you better performance.
>>Susannah Raub: You can also check out the
marker clusters that are available online
including one that you had in the front row.
Yep.
>>Q: Do you have any suggestions for measuring
like CPU load of the browser?
Sometimes it's easy to measure JavaScript
pausing or running too long.
But sometimes, different ways of rendering
things take more.
>>Marc Ridey: Have you looked at SpeedTracker?
>>Q: No, not deeply, actually.
>>Marc Ridey: Okay, so SpeedTracker will give
you information on CPU usage for everything
in the browser on Chrome.
So it will tell you how much CPU to the millisecond
you spend on parsing, on rendering, on doing
server request.
So it's a very good tool for doing that.
In particular, it will highlight to you if
you have combinations of -- if you have some
bad JavaScript that constantly modify DOM
elements.
So you have a loop where you set attributes
and do something else, set attributes, do
something else, and it will show you that
the browser is continuously doing render of
that render of that render of that.
And it will help you identify this kind of
performance heat.
So SpeedTracker will go to the CPU level to
show you where all the time is spent in executing
JavaScript.
>>Q: Cool.
Do you know -- does anything in IE do that?
>>Marc Ridey: No, I don't think so.
[chuckling]
>>Q: Thanks, thanks a lot.
>>Q: Is there anything to effect the scale
of a marker in the Maps v3 API?
>>Marc Ridey: Yes, there's a new parameter
in marker image called "scale image" that
will let you scale a marker.
Have a look at the documentation.
And I've got a blog post that explains a bit
how it's done as well.
>>Q: I was going to say that you mentioned
that there was really no alternative to debugging
on a certain platform other than just saying
console.log.
You could always just put things to the page
itself, because I have personal experience
with not liking that.
Because if you don't homogenize that object
or leave a console log in there, it breaks
it from any browsers that don't have that
there.
So just a word of advice if anybody has had
that issue.
>>Susannah Raub: Yes, we also use that technique
from time to time, particularly when we need
to go back and debug things also on IE6, and
>>Q: Anything that doesn't have a console.
>>Marc Ridey: It's okay for debugging, but
affects performance.
So, if you're trying to do performance test,
it's a bit of a problem, because you cause
the browser to rerender or to reprocess its
DOM.
>>Susannah Raub: We can take this question
from the Wave.
>>Q: Is there a feature planned for v3 that
covers similar functionality to Mapplets?
>>Susannah Raub: Not currently. But the Issue
Tracker is your friend. Yes.
>>Q: Hi there. I have a question about the
zooming supports built into mobile browsers,
pinch zoom or press the little buttons.
Did you try to make use of any of those or
just disable them totally?
What did you do when you came across the zooming
support that's built into browsers and how
do you handle that?
>>Susannah Raub: So we disabled the default
-- or we canceled the default events for
the touch events so that we don't scale the
page when you're in the map.
So as long as your pinch is inside the map,
we won't scale -- or your drag is inside the
map, we won't drag the page.
And I think it's either "canceled" or "stop
propagation."
>>Marc Ridey: That's only for the iPhone obviously,
because for the other browsers, you don't
get that event, so you have no capability
of canceling it. You can.
>>Susannah Raub: Well, Android, you get it,
but just not for Pinch.
But same thing for your drag.
>>Marc Ridey: You can set some metatags at
the top of your page to restrict zooming altogether.
So for our test pages and particular -- it's
quite standard for the iPhone to set the tag
at the top to say "min zoom / max zoom is
one, no user zooming," and so on.
And that stops the pinching from having a
zoom effect if you want the UI to stay always
the same size.
>>Susannah Raub: And for a full-screen web
app, you would most likely want that feature.
In fact, the map will render best when the
scale is set and you don't allow -- once you
start scaling a page on a desktop or on the
mobile, we get artifacts between tiles and
-- it's life kind of with the browsers. Mm-hmm?
>>Q: One more question. Do you have any plans
to support middle mouse scroll zoom sensitivity?
Like, for example, using the Apple magic mouse
on the MacBooks, or anything?
It's really sensitive, so it causes the zoom
to just
>>Susannah Raub: We've seen that, haven't
we?
I think we've observed that.
File it at Issue in the Issue Tracker.
It's something that we should probably fix
on the MacBook -- just haven't prioritized
it yet.
We're using more MacBooks now, so you can
expect it.
Yeah, that might happen sooner now that it's
in our daily life.
>>Q: Sorry, one more. Have you guys been telling
ppk of QuirksMode about your findings with
these events on different mobile phones?
I'm sure he'd be interested -- or getting
it from him?
>>Susannah Raub: We have not talked to him.
We look at his stuff sometimes.
>>Q: Yeah, he has an extensive chart of all
this stuff.
I'm sure he'd be really happy if you told
him of this stuff or just linked him to this
presentation, because he keeps a big master
table that a lot of people use for compatibility.
>>Susannah Raub: Yeah, we refer to that one,
so.
Any other questions?
[pause]
All right. Well, thank you.
And good luck developing your cross-platform
web applications.
We look forward to seeing them.
[Applause]